bien monsieur le Président Madame et et
messieurs les membres et experts du la
Commission nationale d'évaluation des
des recherches et étude relative à la
gestion des matières et des déchets
radioactifs c'est l'intitulé exact de la
CNE
2 mes chers collègues je suis très
heureux particulièrement heureux de vous
accueillir aujourd'hui au Sénat dans une
une salle une des salles délocalisées du
Sénat pour cette première réunion de
l'Office reconstitué à la suite du du
renouvellement
du Sénat le le moins dernier le 24
septembre dernier qui a donné vous le
savez
certainement reconstitution du bureau et
donc ma désignation en tant que
président de cet office au côté du
premier vice-président Pierre
Henry donc la délégation de la cne2 qui
se présente devant nous est forte de
quatre personnes j'ai le plaisir de
souhaiter la bienvenue à son président
Vincent lagau à son vice-président
Christophe Fournier également à Philippe
gillochet et Catherine
Noel je me suis trompé alors pour
peut-être pour en particulier pour les
nouveaux membres vous dire que la la
cne2 la Commission nationale
d'évaluation dite cne2 a été instituée
par la loi du 28 juin 2006 relative à la
gestion durable des des matières et des
déchets radioactifs elle succède à une
première commission qui
s'appelait la même façon CNE 1
commission d'évaluation créée par la loi
Bataille du 30 décembre 1991 relative
donc cette loi aux recherches et à la
gestion des déchets radioactifs la cne2
a pour mission d'évaluer l'état
d'avancement des recherches et des
études relatives à la gestion des
matières et des déchets nucléaires pour
en tirer un rapport donc annuel adressé
au Parlement c'est la loi et transmis à
l'opexte avant sa
publication cette commission est composé
de de 12 membres pour moitié désignés
par le gouvernement sur proposition des
académies des sciences et des sciences
morales et politiques et pour l'autre
moitié désigné à parité par l'Assemblée
nationale et le Sénat sur proposition de
l'opexte et euh sa composition est
renouvelée par moitié tous les 3 ans ce
qui n'est pas sans rappeler le
fonctionnement du Sénat je rappelle
j'indique à ce stade que ces ces membres
exercent leur mission à titre bénévole
il faut le saluer à l'heure donc où
l'urgence climatique nous amène à
considérer sous un jour plus favorable
l'énergie fournie par la fission
atomique l'énergie nucléaire l'industrie
du même non voit poindre un nouveau un
renouveau laissant prévoir la
construction prochaine en France et sans
doute à l'étranger de plusieurs
réacteurs ainsi que l'arrivée de
réacteurs innovants dans ce contexte
dynamique la question du stockage des
géologique des déchets en aval du cycle
donc n'a rien perdu de son acuité bien
au contraire le rapport numéro numéro 17
de la cne2 vous allez nous n présenter
votre rapport annuel pour cette année
2023 et donc un point d'étape
extrêmement important pour évaluer la
situation dans dans ce domaine sensible
de la gestion des matières et des
déchets radioactifs ainsi que les
évolutions envisageable au travers des
progrès de la science et des
technologies nous serons donc très
attentifs à la présentation que vous
avez préparé vous allez également nous
faire part des enseignements que vous
avez tiré d'un voyage d'Ét de
Royaume-Uni euh cet été me semble-t-il
si la situation énergétique de ce pays
est assez différente de celle de la
France il faut convenir que
l'implication ancienne de ces deux pays
et leur intérêt renouvelés pour
l'énergie nucléaire font de leur
comparaison un exercice pertinent et
plus
qu'utile est-ce que monsieur le Premier
Vice-Président vous voulez ajouter
quelques mots avant qu'on passe à la
présentation de ce
rapport dans ce cas je vous donne la
parole monsieur l'anot président de la
commission et nous aurons bien sûr toute
l'attitude pour poser les questions que
vous le souhaiterez mes chers
collègues merci monsieur le Président
euh monsieur le Premier Vice-Président
mesdames messieurs les députés mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs merci de nous
recevoir aujourd'hui pour effectivement
présenter nos nos travaux que nous avons
résumés dans le rapport numéro 17 de la
de la CN2 alors j'avais préparé quelques
transparents pour expliquer ce que
c'était que la cne2 mais vous avez eu la
la la bienveillance de de le faire à ma
place je vais simplement donc vous avez
insisté sur le fait que les les membres
de les 12 membres de la la CNE sont sont
bénévoles je vais juste insister sur le
fait que nous couvrons un domaine
d'expertise très
varié qui couvre la chimie la physique
nucléaire les sciences des matériaux les
sciences de l'ingénieur et puis la
géologie l'hydrogéologie des des choses
qui sont particulièrement utiles pour le
le suivi du du du dossier CGO dont on
reparlera tout à l'heure
euh alors le le mode de fonctionnement
de de la
CNE la CNE procède des
auditions toute l'année des auditions
des des acteurs de de la loi le le COA
le DF Orano
et et l'ra bien sûr et nous effectuons
aussi des des visites techniques euh en
France et à l'étranger j'aurai
l'occasion de revenir dessus tout à
l'heure
euh outre le rapport qu'on qu'on remet
tous les ans euh vous l'avez dit c'est
c'est écrit dans la loi nous pouvons euh
être saisis par l'OPEC sur des sujets
particuliers c'est arrivé ces dernières
années par exemple sur le l'impact de la
crise covid sur sur la filière nucléaire
en particulier la partie cyle cycle du
combustible ou plus récemment sur les
euh les les nouveaux réacteurs
alors je vais rentrer tout de suite dans
le les commentaires sur le le rapport 17
euh en éclairant quelques quelques
messages issus de de de ce rapport en
commençant par la partie matière
nucléaire et combustible pour les
réacteurs du du futur alors vous l'avez
dit la situation évolue très fortement
sur la sur les de de très nombreux
projets de de nouveaux réacteurs elle
évolue également euh par euh la
géopolitique et la politique nationale
je reviendrai pas sur le discours de
Belfort et les les différents CPN qui se
sont succéderé depuis un an et demi
maintenant
euh des évolutions majeures dans le dans
le paysage qui appelle à des décisions
alors on est dans le dans le domaine du
nucléaire euh les décisions doivent être
prises assez vite vu l'urgence des des
différentes de de ces évolutions mais
elle nous engage sur le très long terme
euh on est dans nucéaire une
installation va va vivre pendant 30 40
50 ans d'où l'importance de regarder ça
de de manière très attentive alors dans
les études présenté à la à la Commission
les les acteurs de la loi jusqu'à
l'année dernière he les acteurs de la
loi se sont limités à des scénarios
cohérents avec la PPE c'est normal hein
c'est le c'est le rôle sauf que cette
PPE est en total décalage avec les
nouvelles orientations euh à la fois
politique et et géopolitique donc la
Commission recommande qu'une nouvelle
PPE définisse très rapidement des
scénarios de puissance électrique
installé qui sont en accord avec les les
orientations stratégiques notamment
l'augmentation de la durée de vie des
des réacteurs la construction des
réacteurs des des nouveaux réacteurs et
également euh éventuellement les les les
les petits réacteurs qui sont
actuellement en en projet le tout et ça
c'est le rôle de la de la CNE en prenant
en compte la euh la totalité du cycle du
du combustible y compris la fermeture du
du cycle alors
euh sur la la partie matière nucléaire
la la Commission souhaite insister sur
les impératifs de de souveraineté euh
qui ont été rappelés par euh différents
éléments euh récents et de ce point de
vue-là
euh l'idée de tirer le meilleur parti
euh des matières euh est quelque chose
qui paraît euh euh pertinent alors c'est
aujourd'hui en partie réalisé par le le
mon recyclage en en Rep qu'on fait
depuis de de très nombreux années c'est
un c'est opérationnel et c'est
indispensable de poursuivre dans dans
cette voieà euh pour les même
considération de de souveraineté alors
la Commission recommande premièrement de
porter en priorité les efforts de RD sur
le déploiement de réacteurs à spectre
rapide qui sont les seuls à permettre de
la fermeture du cycle donc donc la
meilleure valorisation possible des des
matières que ce soit le le plutonium ou
l'uranium l'uranium impauvri de ce point
de vueu là le développement des petits
réacteurs avancés à spectre rapide des
choses qu'on voit apparaître alors
portter par le par le privé hein euh
peut contribuer à progresser très
rapidement sur cette technologie
beaucoup plus rapidement qu'on pouvait
l'imaginer il y a il y a quelques années
seulement et donc on regarde ça de de
manière très très attentive et il nous
paraît que cette cette voie du du
réacteurs des des réacteurs à neutron
rapide est une voie plus pertinente que
le multirecyclage en Rep qui est par
ailleurs étudié par par les acteurs de
la loi par ailleurs toujours pour les
questions de de souveraineté réaffirmer
le statut de matière énergétique pour
les stocks d'uranium appauvri d'uranium
de
retraitement dans dans une moindre
mesure et puis le le le plutonium nous
paraît quelque chose de
d'indispensable alors euh concernant la
la fermeture du cycle je viens d'en
parler très rapidement avec le les ce
qui se passe sur le le domaine des des
des
projets de de de nouveaux réacteurs
avancés
euh on souhaite souligner euh que sur
cette cette partie cycle donc la partie
cycle dépend de des usines de
particulier de de la hag de de
Melox usines qui auront besoin d' être
euh renouvelé
renforcé rénové vers 2040 alors compte
tenu des des des délais d'instruction à
la fois des industriels premièrement
puis de l'ASN évidemment et enfin des
délais de de construction euh ben la
prise de décisions doit arriver dès
maintenant enfin
2025 de ce point de vue là euh alors on
a déjà eu des des des études
préliminaires qui nous ont été
présentées sauf que ces études se de
base et c'est normal à nouveau sur la
l'ancienne ENF la PPE actuelle qui est
en décalage avec les les les les
nouvelles orientations
politique il est il est pour nous
indispensable que la que les acteurs de
la loi et en particulier ceux qui qui
sont qui qui sont concernés par la la
mise à jour de de ces usines dispose
d'une mise à jour de la PP ou d'une
nouvelle PPE qui lui permette qui leur
permettent de d'instruire la décision
gouvernementale dans leur
décision
d'investissement alors je vais passer à
la partie gestion des déchets en
commençant par le cas des déchets favl
et en remarque préliminaire c'est vrai
pour tous les déchets hein mais je vais
le le mettre ici euh la Commission
considère que les stockages quel que
soit le type de déchet qu'ils recevront
sont des ressources rares c'est
compliqué de fabriquer un stockage c'est
compliqué de trouver l'endroit où on met
le stockage c'est compliqué de qualifier
ce ce stockage euh euh et donc il faut
pas gaspiller on va dire cette cette
capacité de de stockage donc il faut les
utiliser de manière optimale alors sur
le point particulier des des déchets
favl aujourd'hui il n'existe pas de
solution de stockage identifié pour les
favl le landra travaille dessus et la
Commission insiste depuis plusieurs
années sur la nécessité de de progresser
à la fois sur l'identification et aussi
sur la qualification des des filières de
gestion euh pour ces déchets faible
activité vie longue euh sachant que la
majorité de ces déchets sont déjà
produits alors landra travaille sur ce
sur ce sujet elle elle étudie
actuellement un projet de de site de
stockage à faible profondeur à vendœuvre
sous laine sur la communauté de commune
de vendœuvre sous laine
euh alors nous comprenons des des
présentations que que nous avons eu de
de landendra
que ce ce site ne recevrait pas la
totalité des des favl mais seulement une
partie des des des des déchets qui serit
qualifieré pour ce pour ce pour ce site
euh pour nous avancer dans la
qualification de ce site y compris s'il
ne reçoit qu'une partie des déchets FVL
c'est déjà un pas en avant et donc il me
paraît indispensable de continuer sur
cette
trajectoire pour le cas des déchets
haute activité et moyenne activité
viongue alors vous devez savoir que
landra a déposé début 2023 euh sa
demande d'autorisation de de création
pour le projet CGO donc le centre de
stockage de déchets de hamoyen activité
à vieongue
euh alors
ce cette demande d'autorisation de
création s'appuie sur une très longue
historique de de d'études et recherch
plus de plus de 30 ans de recherche que
ce soit dans des laboratoires académique
ou à l'endra évidemment également dans
des partenaires à l'étranger qui sont
institutionnels ou ou académiques ces
travaux ont été faits dans des
laboratoires de surface ils ont été
faits également dans le laboratoire
souterrain euh de de de de Bur qui se
trouve exactement dans la même couche
géologique que celui qui qui est destiné
à accueillir
CGO alors conformément à la loi de 2006
la Commission doit rendre un avis
scientifique sur cette demande
d'autorisation de création et nous la
devons au Parlement
euh alors je vais
euh sortir de du du rapport ceci n'est
pas dans le rapport mais il me semblait
pertinent de de faire un petit rappel
sur la sur la méthode d'instruction donc
le le dossier d'autorisation de création
a été déposé début 2023
l'instruction de de sûreté donc
technique a été confié à la SN qui va
bien sûr s'appuyer sur sur son bras
technique l'IRSN et par ailleurs nous
avons l'instruction scientifique qui est
menée par par la CNE en parallèle de de
nombreuses concertations qui continuent
sur sur le site donc l'objectif de
rendre à la fois pour pour la SN et la
CNE un rapport au bout de 3 ans
euh et puis ensuite la procédure suivra
avec la mise à jour de de la DAC en
fonction des recommandations de de
laasn l'enquête publique et finalement
l'instruction en vue de la du décret
alors pour la CNE l'instruction du du
dossier est en cours on s'est emparé des
alors de mémoire 23 pièces du
dossier qui présente quelqu une dizaine
de milliers de pages
euh donc nous nous nous emparons de ces
de ces pièces du dossier mais nous avons
également à notre disposition d'autres
d'autres documents des documents
scientifiques par exemple des tests des
publications à dans des revues à comité
de lecture qui qui sur le sur lequel
enfin auquel les pièces du dossier font
référence et puis nous nous interdisons
pas de faire des demande spécifique à à
l'endra pour des compléments
d'information sur des sur sur certains
points donc l'objet de de de la CNE dans
cette instruction c'est de vérifier la
robustesse des des fondements
scientifiques du du dossier la
pertinence et la démonstration des
modèles qui sont utilisés pour pour la
démonstration et puis la plus
généralement la véité de la démarche
scientifique et technique en particulier
sur des partie clé du du stockage donc
j'insiste la CNE n'a pas pour rôle de
faire une instruction de sûreté c'est le
le rôle de l'ASN et nous n'en piiétons
pas sur ce sur ce
sujet euh un petit point sur les
alternatives au stockage de déchets des
déchets ultimes
euh alors on s'est déjà exprimé très
souvent sur le sur le sur le sujet la
Commission considère qu'il n'y a pas de
lieu de remettre en cause le consensus
scientifique international et qu'il n'y
a et qu'aucune solution d'entrroposage
ne peut constituer une alternative au
stockage profond
euh la transmutation ce qui est la
principale voie étudiée pour comme comme
alternative euh
ne permet pas de s'affranchir d'une
installation de de stockage elle peut
traiter un certain nombre de de déchets
mais à la fin il reste des déchets
ultimes il
reste les déchets vitrifiés que qu'on ne
pourra pas retraiter de toute façon et
il reste aussi les déchets mavl qui qui
ne sont pas susceptible de de de d'être
d'être traité donc dans tous les cas il
restera un un stockage qui qui est
indispensable alors je vais
euh je sors un petit peu des des travaux
de la commission pour signaler que un
comité a été mis en place par le le
PNGMDR sur les sur les
alternatives ce comité regroupe de
nombreux experts y compris deux
personnes de la CNE qui ont été
sollicité pour pour ce comité et puis la
la société civile qui fait également
partie de ce de ce comité du PNGMDR
alors les travaux sont totalement
indépendants de de ceux de la la CNE
même si le président de ce comité est un
ancien président de de CNE mais qui bah
je qui qui a quitté la CNE depuis et qui
n'a pour éviter les conflits d'intérêts
a totalement coupé les ponts avec avec
nous
euh alors euh on suit de bien évidemment
toutes ces toutes ces idées de
d'alternative et on l'avait déjà exprimé
dans le dans le rapport numéro 16 la CNE
euh étudiera euh toutes les propositions
alors je vaux dire scientifiquement
crédible euh pour euh pour les comme
comme alternative euh dans le pour les
déchets euh alors je reviens sur
stockage géologique ressources rares les
la
transmutation alors si elle ne permet
pas de de s'affranchir d'un d'un
stockage permet d'optimiser
éventuellement le le stockage en
réduisant l'emprise du stockage en
réduisant la quantité de de déchets
qu'on met dedans et donc c'est quelque
chose qu'on regarde de manière très
attentive alors je vais passer très
rapidement sur les déchets TFA qui
appelle pas de remarque très particulièr
les des déchets bénéficient déjà d'une
d'une fière
opérationnelle elle peut être bousculée
dans ces dans ces calendriers en
fonction de l'avancement du du
démantelllement et de différents projets
du du cycle donc on continue à regarder
ça mais je jeis garder du temps pour
pararler d'autres choses alors je passe
au réacteurs innovants et à leur
combustible donc je rappelle le la
césine de de la CNE spécifiquement donc
pour regarder évaluer
dans le cadre de ces travaux l'impact
des des réacteurs innovant alors nous
n'avons pas vocation regarder les
réacteurs c'est pas c'est pas la mission
de la CNE par contre l'impact de ces
réacteurs sur le cycle que ce soit
l'amont et laaval fait partie de de nos
attributions et le l'OPEX a souhaité le
le
rappeler en mars 2022
alors donc il vous a pas échappé qu'il y
a actuellement beaucoup de projets sur
la scène la scène française et
internationale plus de de 80 projets de
petit réacteurs ou petit réur acteur
innovant SMR Amr il nous appartient pas
à nouveau de de de juger ses projets en
particulier
euh sur l'année
2022-223 pendant lequel la la France
était engagée dans un processus de
sélection de de projets dans le dans
l'appel à
projet France 2030 cela dit ça nous a
pas empêché de d'auditionner un certain
nombre de de de porteurs de projet pour
regarder queles étaient les spécificités
de leur projet et leur la manière dont
il ils envisageaient la gestion du du du
cycle alors je dois dire que d'une
manière générale euh les projets mettent
assez peu l'accent sur le combustible et
encore moins sur l'aval du cycle ce qui
nous interpelle légèrement et donc nous
recommandons que pour tous les réacteurs
innovants qui sont proposés pour le pour
pour la France euh le ces projets sont
regardés de de manière holistique euh et
en en incluant la partie
approvisionnement en combustible et la
la partie aval du cycle y compris le le
retraitement euh s'il le s'il le faut
euh on va même au-delà de ça en
recommandant que les projets qui
bénéficieraient de de de fonds publics
euh et l'obligation de de présenter leur
la manière dont ils envisagent la
gestion à la fois de du combustible il y
a des aspects de d'approvisionnement et
de souveraineté sur ce sur son
combustible et puis puis la partie aval
du
cycle voilà je continue un petit peu sur
les SMR Amr cette fois-ci les en parlant
des enjeux internationaux
euh alors le modèle économique des des
smmr repose sur l'effet de série
euh donc les SMR sont réputés être moins
efficaces que des gros réacteurs donc
plus cher
au au kilwhur électrique euh sa sauf
que l'objectif de ces projets c'est de
se récupérer sur l'effet de série pour
diminuer les les coûts de de
construction et donc proposer des des
prix de de l'électricité qui soient
attractifs y compris vis-à-vis des des
grands réacteurs al c'est pas encore
c'est pas encore démontré mais c'est en
tout cas le le leur souhait
euh
les donc pour atteindre ces objectifs de
d'effet de série ben il faut une
certaine standardisation
euh alors je tiens à insister là-dessus
les les projets ne seront possibles que
s'ils sont autorisés par les autorités
de sûreté des pays dans lesquels il ils
déposent malgré tout il nous il nous
semble que la pour pour ces objectifs de
standardisation et de on va dire
convergence ou consolidation des des
marchés il y aura probablement des des
standards de fait qui vont qui vont
apparaître alors soit imposé par des des
autorités de sûreté qui vont se qui vont
se concerter ou pas soit par la la
consolidation du du du du marché euh le
corollaire c'est que il n'y aura pas la
place pour tous et euh euh les premiers
arrivés ou les plus costauds euh seuls
euh
survivront voilà alors je passe au
dernier chapitre de du rapport 17 qui
concerne le euh 6e euh pardon le 5e
PNGMDR alors vers un 6e PNGMDR pourquoi
donc nous sommes aujourd'hui dans le 5e
plan national de gestion des matières et
déchs radioactifs qui repose sur une PPE
je l'ai déjà dit plusieurs fois qui
aujourd'hui n'est absolument alors
obsolè c'est peut-être un gros mot ici
mais en tout cas une PPE qui n'est pas
du tout alignée avec les nouvelles
orientations de la politique nationale
euh il est donc important de revisiter
ce ce plan soit on le modifiant soit en
le le transformant directement en 6e
pngmtr et nous avons donc passé un
moment à étudier ce PNGMDR pour en tirer
les leçons qu'est-ce qui marche bien
qu'est-ce qui marche pas et proposer euh
nos recommandations pour la mise à jour
de ce PNG mdr alors euh première
remarque le 5e PNG mdr porte beaucoup
d'attention sur l'aval du cycle et assez
peu sur Laam sur le sur le combustible
et donc je vais aujourd'hui ne commenter
que la partie la partie
amant donc pour la commission
euh nous considérons qu'il est d'une
importance stratégique de de de
poursuivre et d'accélérer les études sur
la valorisation des matières
radioactives qui sont actuellement
entreposé sur le sur le sol à nouveau
dans une optique de souveraineté
énergétique du du pays euh deuxème
deuxème point que que je veux souligner
euh il nous paraît important de
d'étudier la question des nouveaux
combustibles y compris leur impact sur
le le le cycle des matières et des
déchets
euh que ce soit pour les réacteurs
actuels les réacteurs euh les nouveaux
réacteurs PR2 et éventuellement les des
réacteurs
innovants voilà j'en ai fini avec la
partie rapport
je monsieur le Président est-ce que vous
souhaitez que je continue directement
sur le le rapport de mission au
Royaume-Uni très bien alors donc mission
au Royaume-Uni en juin 2023 sous le le
les les les hospices d'une autre vision
pour le renouveau du nucléaire alors
quelques éléments euh de euh de de de
situation pour pour le Royaume-Uni euh
le Royaume-Uni s'est fixé des objectifs
de réduction des émissions de de C2 de
de CO2 et en particulier euh pour la la
la la décarbonation de de l'électricité
elle elle compte là-dessus en premier
lieu sur l'éolien en mer qui doit
représenter une la la majeure partie de
de son
effort première partie et euh en second
lieu sur le nucléaire
euh remarque annexe aujourd'hui le le
Royaume-Uni la production nucléaire de
enfin d'électricité par le le nucléaire
auxat au Royaume-Uni est faite par des
réacteurs AGR qui ne peuvent pas être
prolongés pour des raisons techniques et
euh au-delà de 2025 il ne restera que un
seul
réacteur ancienne formule au au au
Royaume-Uni d'où l'importance pour le
Royaume-Uni dans sa stratégie d'utiliser
le nucléaire comme deuxème levier de
décarbonation d'accélérer très
rapidement sur la la construction de de
nouvelles centrales alors le Royaume-Uni
a annoncé un plan de de relance du du du
nucléaire euh pour les 30 prochaines
années et qui repose grosso modo sur
trois volets un premier volet très
rapidement avec la construction de de
réacteurs de de forte puissance il y a
trois paires qui sont qui sont prévu
dont inkle point en cours de
construction euh dans une deuxième étape
des des smmr et je reviendraessus dans
dans un instant et et puis dans une
étape un peu plus lointaine des des
Amr alors le projet de PR de
construction de PR à une clay point
avance bien et à vrai dire c'est un
retour d'expérience qui sera très utile
pour pour la France et je pense que les
acteurs se sont déjà emparés de
de de la manière de de
construire de EDF
Energy qui est le le le le maître
d'œuvre maîre d'ouvrage et par ailleurs
le projet sizewell C doit prendre la la
suite sur sur ce sujet alors concernant
le le programme SMR le le Royaume-Uni a
un choix qui est de privilégier des des
projets qui reposent sur des
technologies déjà éprouvées donc
l'objectif c'est des projets sans
innovation aucune euh pour la la
construction de de SMR de manière à
accélérer la la mise en service et
faciliter la la qualification alors
quand je dis sans innovation c'est sans
innovation sur la partie réacteur les
innovations elles sont concentrées sur
la partie méthode de construction par
exemple avec une donc on parle de SMR un
Small modular réacteur euh les les les
projets qu'on qu'on a vu vont au-delà
avec une méthode de construction qui
elle-même est modulaire ce qui leur
permet de réutiliser d'unun d'un site de
construction à l'autre les mêmes les
mêmes éléments donc des innovations sur
les méthodes
de construction sur l'ingénierie mais
pas sur les sur les réacteurs euh le le
Royaume-Uni a a lancé comme la France
avant la France une un appel à projet
alors le l'appel à projet est ouvert euh
on a l'impression que alors même si même
si rien est dit que l'Angleterre va
probablement s'engager dans des filières
qui sont déjà éprouvées chez eux donc la
filière HTR haute température euh et REP
enfin d'abord REP puis
HTR
euh l'Angleterre contrairement à ce
qu'on a pu voir ailleurs et
contrairement à ce qu'on a pu discuter
avec les porteurs de projet en France a
pris euh en main euh très très
rapidement euh la la question des
combustibles alors pas vraiment dans une
dans une optique sy mais en tout cas
dans une optique euh euh
approvisionnement du du combustible et
puis dernière remarque euh le
Royaume-Uni alors a beaucoup misé sur le
sur le privé donc c'est exactement ce
que fait la France aujourd'hui
euh mais ces premières expériences ont
monttré que ça n'avançait pas
suffisamment et donc paradoxalement au
pays de de de de Madame tcher
euh le le gouvernement assume un certain
interventionnisme dans euh dans la mise
en place de de cette nouvelle stratégie
nucléaire
euh alors j'ai j'ai je viens d'annoncer
que le que que le le Royaume-Uni
regarder de manière très attentiv la
partie combustible euh malheureusement
ou euh enfin en tout cas euh c'est c'est
un fait euh le gouvernement a choisi de
d'assumer le l'abandon nucléaire pardon
l'abandon du cycle fermé excusez-moi
euh euh alors je juste une petite incise
sur ce sur ce point
euh les usines de
retraitement au Royaume-Uni ont fermé il
y a quelques années euh alors pour
diverses raisons mais il nous semble que
la raison principale c'est euh l'absence
de décision
sur ces sur ces usines donc plus qu'une
décision c'est une fermeture
par euh non décision euh ça arrive euh
et en tout cas donc le gouvernement
assume cette cet état de fait et donc
pour le moment est dans une dans une
optique de d'abandon du cycle fermé
euh je vais passer rapidement sur le le
l'aval du cycle avec donc nous avons été
visiter le le site de de de cellafield
alors c'est un un site historique hein
qui euh concentre on va dire beaucoup de
problèmes euh qui illustre la manière
dont euh
le le l'industrie nucléaire a fonctionné
il y a quelques dizaines d'années euh en
laissant derrière elle euh un certain
nombre de choses de problème à régler
euh aujourd'hui ça coûte 2 milliards de
livres par an pour ce seul site euh pour
une centaine d'années voilà euh bon par
ailleurs sur la la question du stockage
définitif donc stockage géologique pour
les déchets de de haute activité
l'Angleterre est euh en recherche d'
site
voilà et puis je vais terminer avec
cette petite remarque le donc je reviens
sur les questions de de souveraineté les
questions de souveraineté concernent les
combustibles qu'on a qu'on a chez nous
concern aussi les réacteurs qu'on est
capable de de de de fabriquer mais elle
le la la la souveraineté finalement elle
est sur la maîtrise technique de
l'ensemble de de la chaîne que ce soit
les réacteurs la fabrication du
combustible le le retraitement et et par
derrière le la l'évacuation des des
déchets dans des
conditions
correctes et bah je vais souligner que
les les britannique de de ce point de
vue-l se sont mis en capacité de
disposer de cette S é pour la
fabrication du du combustible il dispose
à la fois des usines de conversion et
d'enrichissement et de fabrication du du
combustible ce qui leur permet de
maîtriser pour eux-même le toute la
chaîne du du combustible et puis
accessoirement de viser des des marchés
d'export en particulier pour l'Europe de
l'Est et je pense que j'en ai fini avec
la
présentation merci monsieur le Président
merci pour pour ce travail je sais que
c'est une présentation à une seule voix
mais qu' a y a derrière un travail de
l'ensemble des membres de la CNE nous
allons passer à aux questions mes chers
collègues si vous souhaitez euh avoir
davantage des des éclairages
complémentaires à la fois sur donc la
présentation du du rapport annuel et le
l'éclairage sur ce qui se passe
actuellement au Royaume-Uni je je vous
laisse volontiers la
parole allez-y n'hésitez
pas merci beaucoup merci euh monsieur
mesame en fait j'hésitaé parce que j'ai
une question qui est un petit peu
parallèle je veux savoir si vous pouviez
m'éclairer sur un sur en fait le le le
pilotage en fait he des centrales
nucléaires parce qu'il me semblait que
Royaume-Uni le Royaume-Uni n'a pas ne ne
pratique pas à la différence de la
France un pilotage variable de la
puissance donc la
modulation donc je voulais profiter que
j'ai affaire à des experts pour pour
avoir la réponse je je suis bien
consciente que je déborde un petit peu
de du cœur de de de de notre échange
mais vous souhaitez qu'on comprenne
toutes les questions et qu'on répondent
ou oui peut-être s'il y a d'autres
questions Daniel salmon
oui merci merci pour votre présentation
euh vous avez parlé de de souveraineté
euh pouvez nous dire pouvez-vous nous
dire un mot euh de la gestion de nos
déchets en France avant de s'attacher à
ceux des du Royaume-Uni euh conc une
partie de notre uranium de retraitement
issu du retraitement
l'URT qui va aujourd'hui essentiellement
en Russie voir je dis essentiellement
c'est pratiquement 100 % et qui nous
revient après sous forme duure donc en
terme de souveraineté je pense qu'il y a
il y a un vrai
sujet l'uranium enrichi également pour
une partie entre 40 et 67 % provient de
Russie donc voilà voilà c'est un vrai
questionnement sur notre souveraineté en
lien avec la filière filière
nucléaire quant à ce que vous avez
rapporté de votre visite au Royaume-Uni
c'est plus qu'inquiétant
puisque les sites ont été quand même
laissés je vais pas dire en jacher mais
avec certains silos qui mettront
plusieurs où il y aura plusieurs
décennies pour remettre les choses à peu
près pr à peu près d'qu
avec des investissements comme vous
l'avez dit qui sont colossaux qui
portent sur pratiquement un siècle donc
voilà je pense que votre travail sur le
cycle de vie du
combustible est essentiel et qu'il y a
vraiment matière à faire puisque souvent
on ne parle que du enfin parle beaucoup
du coup de du mgaw issu du nucléaire
mais sans avoir vraiment la perspective
je sais pas si vous travaillez sur le
coût je pense que c'est pas votre
fonction première mais il y a des coûts
des couts différés qui qui me semblent
essentiel à prendre en compte
merci David Ros merci monsieur le
Président oui justement ma question va
un petit peu en complément de ce que
vient de dire au collègue Daniel salmon
c'était sur votre rapport il y a
beaucoup de choses donc stratégiqu
géopolitique scientifique et l'aspect
financier voir économique est pas du
tout dans votre champ de d'investigation
et
d'évaluation
ahard oui merci Stéphane oui en
complément de la question tout à l'heure
de notre collègue Salmon et pour
reprendre un des derniers de de vos
propos concernant le l'enquête en
Grande-Bretagne euh vous parliez de de 2
milliards de livres par an pour traiter
le le site et vous avez ajouté pendant
de nombreuses années quel est le nombre
d'années que vous
estimez j'ai déjà répondu 100
ans également dans par extension du
collègue salmon qui définitivement pose
de de de bons sujets vous évoquiez tout
à l'heure notamment le site Dinkle point
avec l'opérateur def il y a un autre
opérateur qui est présent sur sur site
c'est l'opérateur chinois euh et donc
dans dans la perspective de de cette
dépendance au combustible quel est selon
vous aussi le le rôle de la Chine
aujourd'hui avec les avancées qui qu'il
peuvent avoir notamment sur l'uraniu
faiblement richichi à à fort tenneur et
et sur la les possibilités françaises
aussi de de coopération avec elle dans
les dans les années à venir notamment
effectivement dans le cadre du du
nouveau programme nucléaire annoncé
je vous laisse répondre à cette première
série de questions on aura peut-être
quelques compléments ensuite bien je
vais alors je va faire une réponse très
rapide sur le sur la question
financière alors on en a pas parlé cette
année parce que nous n'avions plus de
financierement d'économistes dans la
dans la
commission la chose est rattrapée depuis
la la
nouvelle le renouvellement de de la de
la commission donc on va se réattaquer à
ces à ces questions
euh je vais
oui alors bon je vais répondre
à de
manière incomplète à la question sur les
sur les coûts différés donc je ne sais
pas répondre aujourd'hui je vais
simplement rappeler un
élément la la Cour des comptes s'était
penchée sur le sur le coût de du
stockage des des des déchets donc on va
dire CG et euh avait estimé que il était
de l'ordre de 2 3 4 % du coût complet de
de de l'électricité donc vous avez un
ordre de grandeur pour pour la partie
pour la partie stockage j'ai pas la
réponse pour pour l'ensemble de de la
filière
euh sur la question c la filde et les
enseignements qu'on peut en en tirer
alors euh j'ai pas été très honnête
puisque j'ai parlé des des anglais j'ai
pas parlé de la France euh vous l'avez
bien souligné euh alors premier
renseignement bah éviter de recommencer
les les erreurs du passé deuxième
enseignement ne pas traîner pour pour
faire le démantèlement puisque attendre
40 ans ça ne règle pas les problèmes au
contraire ça les fait ça les fait
manifestement empirer alors on
s'intéresse au au démantelllement des
installations du du cycle dans le dans
nos attributions de de la
commission alors à titre de de
comparaison pour
le le le budget démentantellement pour
le CEA de mémoire et de de vous
compléterez 700 millions 750 millions
environ par an 750 millions d'euros par
an pour le pour le seul CEA ça n'inclut
pas bien
sûran pour les seules installations
du pour les seules installations du CEA
l'ordre de grandeur annuel du budget
d'assainissement et démantellement est
de l'ordre de 750 millions
d'euros avec pour le alors je parle de C
parce qu'on a on a regardé en détail ce
qui ce qu' faisait un premier enjeu qui
est de réduire le plus tôt possible le
le terme source donc c'est l'opposé de
de cellafield
cfield on a laissé traîner pendant
pendant longtemps donc là le l'objectif
c'est il y a un terme source on le
retire et ensuite ça nous laisse le
temps qu'il faut si si on n pas les
ressources par exemple pour pour traiter
sachant que le terme source est déjà est
déjà retiré
euh peut-être que Philipp tu peux parler
de l'URT et puis de de l'enregistrement
alors SAG son de de l'uranium de
retraitement ce qui est important de de
constater c'est que d'abord les les
volumes sont relativement peu importants
par rapport à la totalité de
l'approvisionnement de nos centrales en
en combustible ce qu'il manque à l'heure
actuelle en France c'est une usine de
conversion de l' de l'URE s'agissant de
de de cette étape là nous n'avons pas
les moyens de faire la conversion de
l'URE en revanche en s'agissant de de de
de
l'enrichissement il sera possible
d'étendre vous savez que Orano est en
train de d'étudier l'extension de son
unité de c'est acté mais donc
concrètement donc la construction va
démarrer donc il s'agit en fait
d'élargir les possibilités les capacités
de traitement donc
d'enrichissement d'oranau et ce ce
problème va être réglé très très
rapidement parce que en fait on on ne
peut pas utiliser les mêmes
cascades pour pour l'uranium de
retraitement que pour l'uranium naturel
donc en fait le le sujet si vous voulez
qui reste encore à déterminer c'est la
question de la conversion de de de
l'uranium donc après après le après
l'enrichissement s'agissant de de encore
une fois des des volumes si vous voulez
que représente l'uranium de retraitement
euh ce sont des volumes très faibles
puisque en fait il y a trois réacteurs
qui utilisent l'uranium de retraitement
ça il est possible que on passe à 4at
mais en tout cas il ne s'agit absolument
pas de la totalité du du parc en
fonctionnement
euh il y a une question sur euh oui
d'abord euh donc les relations EDF et et
CNC euh pour euh pour Inc point bon le
le Royaume-Uni a décidé de se séparer
euh des des des Chinois pour pour la
construction de de ces centrales bon je
pense que enfin les aspects stratégiques
les les regardent je vais pas les les
commenter
euh et en tout cas pour pour la 2ème et
la trème paire euh alors la trème paire
elle est pas encore actée mais la deème
paire euh EDF Energy est le seul le le
le le seul acteur pour la pour la
construction alors la la votre question
c'est prolongé sur la la partie h
leu qui appelle quelques quelques
remarques alors sur les quelques 80
projets don que que j'ai mentionné tout
à l'heure pour les alors pour des
réacteurs de faible puissance on est
confronté à une une question qui est la
moindre efficacité on va dire de du du
cœur du réacteur à cause de des des fes
de
neutrons et cette faible puissance est
compensé de soit enfin par un
enrichissement supérieur de du du du
cœur du Combus comusble soit par de
l'uranium plus concentré en uranium 235
soit par l'utilisation de de plutonium
plus plus
concentré alors pour la plupart des pays
dans dans le monde le plutonium ça
n'existe pas parce que le plutonium
vient du du retraitement
des des combustibles usés et donc la
filière Hu est quelque chose donc highs
low enrich uranium uranium enfin c'est
un oxymor c'est
uranium fortement pas pas fortement
enrichi euh c'est une manière pudique de
dire de l'uranium enrichi à moins de 20
% enfin plus que les 3 4 % desacteurs
habituel et moins que 20 % au-delà
duquel on bascule dans quelque chose qui
est réputé plus proliférant donc ce
hachat ilu est est vu comme un moyen de
compenser cette cette moindre efficacité
des des SMR dans la plupart des pays du
monde la France est dans une situation
un peu différente puisque nous disposons
de de plutonium et les projets portés
par les Français ont plutôt insisté sur
l'utilisation de du plutonium que ce
soit sur des des des filiersr rapides ou
sur l'utilisation d'un d'un combustible
contenant ce plutonum ce qui n'empêche
que le le H leu peut être une
opportunité de marché pour les
opérateurs français alors peut-être pas
pour pour la France mais pour pour pour
l'étranger par ailleurs il existe aussi
des projets en France qui reposent sur
le hlu donc c'est une une question
importante
évidemment euh voilà je pense que j'ai
répondu à presque toutes les questions
sauf le pilotage des des centrales
nucléaires et alors je même si nous nous
sommes experts dans le domaine je pense
que ça dépasse notre notre
expertise je pas juste parce que je
j'avais entendu que la modulation en
fait donc la gestion variable la
puissance impactait le
fonctionnement des centrales puisque ça
implique qu'il faut les arrêter ou voilà
donc et donc les coûts aussi derrière ça
je voulais savoir un peu quel était les
les pratiques et est-ce que c'était de
nature finalement à impacter les
objectifs qui sont des objectifs de
produit et des objectifs de coût de
l'énergie alors effectivement les les
réacteurs de forte puissance sont
réputés ne pas aimer les les excursions
de de puissance donc c'est on arrive à
faire de de la la régulation de ou la
compensation de de réseau avec mais ils
ont pas été conçus pour ça beaucoup de
petits projets enfin de de projets de
petits réacteurs eux insistent justement
sur la capacité de enfin sont conçus
pour pour compléter les venir en
complément des énergies renouvelables
intermittente
donc ça ça fait partie de la conception
d'un certain nombre de de projets voilà
je suis conscient de pas avoir répondu à
votre question
complètement mais voilà vous avez
quelques
éléments Arna basin voulait poser une
question merci monsieur le Président
quand nous avons des entreprises sur nos
territoires qui utilisent des produits
dangereux euh elles sont astreintes par
réglementation à faire des des études de
danger justement qui sont proposé enfin
présenté plutôt aux élus locaux avec des
conséquences sur la population je
voulais savoir si dans vos travaux vous
avez été amené à examiner d'éventuelles
études de danger autour de sites de
stockage même provisoire parce que là on
parle pas de stockage sou-terrain et je
voulais savoir si ces études de danger
intègrent des hypothèses terroristes
parce que malheureusement le monde dans
lequel nous vivons de plus en plus
dangereux et ben on peut tout imaginer y
compris précipiter des a ronf sur des
zones de stockage extérieur et cetera
donc plus généralement est-ce que vous
pouvez nous nous dire ce qu'il en est de
ces études de danger sur ces
stockages je peut-être compléter cette
cette question par une série de
questions personnelles avec bon quelques
observations aussi sur sur votre
présentation et et des remarques sur la
comparaison avec le avec le
Royaume-Uni d'abord évidemment vous
rejoindre sur l'urgence d'une nouvelle
PPE d'une pration plurriannuelle de de
l'énergie qui nous était annoncé chers
collègu parlementaires avant l'été puis
avant la fin de cette année 2023 et
contenu de l'agenda parlementaire dont
nous avons connaissance que je ne vois
pas poindre dans notre dans nos travaux
parlementaire donc je rejoins évidemment
votre
inquiétude parce que c'est c'est pas
seulement un un texte C avec des
orientations de de production
énergétique c'est aussi des des
obligations je rappelle qu'aujourd'hui
l'état fr
français ni plus ni moins hors la loi
par rapport à sa propre loi nous sommes
depuis la loi de 2006 sur une obligation
de fonctionner avec un cycle fermé le
cycle fermé ne se ne peut se réaliser
qu'avec des neutrons rapides la filière
des neutrons rapides et aujourd'hui nous
avons abandonné faut-il le rappeler en
2019 cette filière des des neutrons
rapides avec le projet Astrid qui avait
été initié il y a matsan plus d'une
décennie donc c'est ex ex et ce texte là
est toujours en vigueur donc on a un
vrai on a un vrai sujet de de conformité
si je puis dire de nos objectifs avec la
réalité des des pratiques de la filière
nucléaire que nous proposons dans notre
dans notre pays donc le sujet de la la
programmation pluriannuelle de l'énergie
est vraiment
essentiel je rappelle aussi que dans
cette optique de cycle fermé la
transmutation est un élément absolument
essentiel j'aimerais bien peut-être que
vous nous rappeliez dans quelle mesure
cette transmutation permet de réduire la
quantité de déchets à à retraiter parce
que on se pose des questions sur la
gestion de nos déchets en en aval bien
sûr la question à monont est importante
mais en aval c'est extrêmement important
vous évoquiez par exemple absence de
filière sur les favl sur les les déchets
de faible activité à
vielong peut-être que les décisions sont
sont encore pas programmées mais en tout
cas on peut
se on peut avoir on peut
reconnaître les décisions successives du
du pays pour traiter ce qui n'a pas été
fait pour traiter nos déchets ce qui n'a
pas été fait on le voit avec la sur au
Royaume-Uni avec les problèmes que ça
pose aujourd'hui donc nouvelle PPE
essentiel transmutation faut-il à un
moment donné oui ou
non confirmer notre notre orientation
vers un cycle fermé et donc vers vers
des neutrons rapides et donc relancer
des des recherches ou bien tout
simplement prendre un un concept pour ne
pas dire un process industriel qui est
déjà trouvver dans d'autres dans
d'autres pays
h deuxème point sur la c'est presque de
la sémantique mais mais tous les
spécialistes qui travaillent sur le
sujet savent que ça n'en est pas d'abord
je je réfute le l'expression de
prolonger la durée de vie des réacteurs
puisque la durée de vie d'un réacteur
n'a jamais été fixée il y a pas eu
d'obsolescence programmée sur les
réacteurs nucléairees nous luttons les
uns et les autres contre l'
l'obsolescence programmée dans tas de
domaines euh euh il n'y a pas eu
d'obsolescence programmée avant l'heure
pour les réacteurs nucléaires lorsque le
plan Mesmer a été initié dans les années
70 simplement c'était une ça a été
exprimé d'ailleurs comme ça par les
ingénieurs nous sommes tranquilles
pendant 40 ans donc je voudrais qu'on il
faut trouver une formulation pour dire
nos réacteurs sont en capacité de
fonctionner encore pendant de longues
années mais nous ne sommes pas sur sur
un sujet de sur le sujet de la fin de
vie avant l'heure c'est un sujet qui va
nous occuper nos travaux parlementaires
mais il y a pas de sujet fin de vie
prolongation de la fin de de la durée de
vie de nos réacteurs un sujet un autre
sujet de sémantique mais là qui n'en est
pas du tout un c'est le statut de
l'uranium
appauvri qui est vous l'avez dit
d'ailleurs qui doit être confirmé comme
un stock stratégique et et ça rejoint
d'ailleurs ma première ma première
question sur les réacteurs à neutron
rapides nous disposons si je ma mémoire
est bonne de 300000 tonnes d'uranium
appauvri sur notre même un peu plus
350000 maintenant d'uranium appauvri sur
notre territoire qui si la filière des
des des neutrons rapides des RNR
aboutissait nous
garantirait plus d'un millier de
production d'électricité avec des des
des surgénérateurs qui plus c'estd sans
production supplémentaire de déchet donc
on voit que les sujets on sait que les
les sujets sont sont liés et ça rejoint
encore un autre un autre point sur les
réacteurs innovants
euh je crois vous avoir entendu dire que
c'était des réacteurs essentiellement
axés sur la filière des neutrons rapides
donc plutôt sur les
Amr et dans ce cas-là il y a moins de
problème de cycle puisque ce que ce que
je viens de dire consiste à à penser que
nous avons
suffisamment et ça rejoint aussi le
sujet de la souveraineté nous avons
suffisamment d'uranium àauvr sur notre
territoire pour alimenter cette filière
même sur des petits réacteurs et puis
dernière chose on peut se féliciter
d'avoir d'être dans un pays où qui a
pris des des décisions peut-être que
dans les décennies précédentes on a
manqué
de de marche en avant sur sur la filière
nucléaire en tout cas on s'est préoccupé
de la la gestion si Go est est un bel
exemple de prise de conscience et de
nécessité d'avoir un site pour
accueillir en en site profond nos nos
déchets ultimes par comparaison le
Royaume-Uni alors peut peut peut-être
s'en orgueillir d'avoir un réacteur qui
sera développé par Rolls-Royce bon ça ça
ça fait chouette mais en l'occurrence ça
ne suffit pas pour avoir une une vision
prospective à long terme sur la gestion
des déchets qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
nous dire par comparaison du du projet
newward qui est le le projet français le
plus avancé dans dans dans ce domaine là
même si on sait qu'il y a une profusion
en France de sujets al j'allais dire
plus ou moins innovant plus innovant les
uns que les autres voire parfois un peu
qui nous promettent mon émerveilles en
l'espace de 5 ans et dont on sait bien
que c'est c'est un horizon tout à fait
inatteignable pour une pour l'innovation
dans dans la mat matière dans la filière
nucléaire bien je vais prendre votre
pause comme l'occasion de de de répondre
à à vos commentaires alors je je vais
commencer par le les études de danger
sur les sur les stockages alors je je
vais faire la différence entre le
l'évaluation de l'évolution de du
stockage sous des conditions on va dire
normales
euh l'évolution géologique l'évolution
liée au changement climatique c'est des
choses qui nous qui je sais pas si c'est
normal ou pas mais en tout cas le le
soockage va subir ce ce genre de chos et
ça c'est des choses qu'on regarde de
très près par contre la partie sûreté au
sens quel est l'impact des intrusions ou
de des actes de malveillance nous
échappent totalement donc ça c'est la il
faut reposer la question à la à la S
donc voilà la réponse que que je voulais
faire alors je vais essayer de je je
vais faire des commentaires généraux et
puis essayer de d'attraper les les
réponses que que vous attendez au au fur
et à mesure euh donc vous avez mentionné
que aujourd'hui la France était hors la
loi vis-à-vis de bah de la loi de de
2006 c'est quelque chose qu'on a
souligné devant l'OPEX d'ailleurs il me
semble que c'était le rapport euh 15 ou
peut-être le 14 et
euh j'étais dans la séance et je me
souviens de visage un peu décomposé dans
le dans dans dans l'assemblée au moment
où on a dit que bah je suis désolé nous
sommes hors la loi ce qui faisait est
quand même mauvais genre dans ce type de
d'assemblée
euh alors euh vous avez parlé d'astride
euh bon pour nous Astrid c'est un projet
qui est abandonné donc on ne on n parle
plus on on s'est désolé au moment où où
il a été euh où il été on a commenté le
le ce que faisait Astrid pendant le le
le temps où le projet existait on s'est
désolé au moment où il a été fermé euh
aujourd'hui bon c'est du passé donc on
ne on ne revient pas de dessus euh euh
alors tout à l'heure j'ai parlé
effectivement des des Amr alors j'ai
peut-être fait
une enfin j'ai peut-être pas été clair
là-dessus les Amr donc c'est alors on va
faire la différence entre les SMR qui
sont des réacteurs on va dire un peu
classique à eut légère et puis les Amr
qui sont tout le reste donc dans les
projets Amr il y a des projets à neutron
rapide mais il y a aussi plein d'autres
choses euh alors le il y a des des
réacteurs à haute température par
exemple qui qui ont pour mission à la
fois d'être électrogène mais aussi de
fabriquer de de la vapeur à très haute
température qui peut être utilisé pour
des process industriels y compris de la
génération d'hydrogène par exemple euh
il y a des projets de réacteurs brûleur
d'actinide spécifiquement fait pour
brûler les les actinides et puis toute
une autre collection y compris des des
réacteurs de de fusion qui sont
probablement un peu plus enfin horizon
de réalisation un peu plus lointin
euh alors ce qui m'amène à à parler de
euh de à revenir sur la le le
commentaire sur la transmutation et les
et les RNR alors je voudrais quand même
faire un un point très très très
particulier euh les RNR ce sont des
réacteurs à neutron rapides qui ont la
particularité de pouvoir euh consommer
de du combustible fertile enfin plus
exactement ils vont brûler de du du
plutonium ou de de enfin du plutonium
qui est régénéré par la fertilisation ou
le le la la la capture neutronique sur
de de l'uranium de 238 donc de l'uranium
appauvri
le but du jeu pour un RNR c'est quand
même de produire de de l'électricité il
se trouve que en fonction de la manière
dont on règle le le le mode de
fonctionnement du du réacteur il peut
produire juste enfin compenser
exactement la quantité de plutonium
produite par rapport la quantité de
plutonum consommée donc il est
isogénérateur et donc là on est dans un
cycle vertueux un cycle fermé dans
lequel en utilisant de l'uraniumovis Don
dont nous avons des stocks hauteur de
350000 tonnes nous devenons indépendant
y compris de de l'amont on a plus besoin
de de mine d'uranium puisque on peut
utiliser cet uranium àie qui fabrique le
plutonium qui lui-même sera consommé
voilà euh je vais faire la différence
avec la
transmutation même si on on est très
près hein la transmutation repose
également sur le donc des des des
neutrons rapides euh
elle est plutôt dessiné à alors détruire
on va dire les les tout ce qui est
au-dessus de de l'uranium dans la
classification périodique alors le
plutonium éventuellement mais euh
surtout les actinides mineures donc nous
considérons que le plutonium est une
matière et donc qu'il a lieu de
l'utiliser de la manière la plus
efficace possible dans un dans un
réacteur à neutron rapide pour fabriquer
de de l'électricité et que le problème
on va dire pour le stockage c'est les
les actinines mineurs améritium curium
et autres donc la transmutation euh vise
plutôt à détruire ces actinines mineures
alors quel va être le quel va être le
l'impact euh de de la transmutation sur
le le stockage donc j'ai dit tout à
l'heure la transmutation ne règle pas le
la question du stockage on a toujours
besoin d'un stockage pourquoi parce
qu'un certain nombre de choses ne
peuvent pas être transmutées donc je je
viendrai après sur qu'est-ce qu'on
transmute mais je je redis mon message
premier euh les vers les les les les
vers déjà retraités enfin le combustible
déjà retraité et donc les déchets sous
forme de verre ne sont pas retraitables
on peut pas imaginer les les les
transmuter
les mavl les déchets de moyenne activité
ne sont pas
transmutables la physique n'est pas
pas la transmutation n'est juste pas pas
imaginable et encore moins pour les FVN
donc on aura besoin de toute façon d'un
stockage pour les veres pour les mavl
qui sont déjà construits et même avec la
transmation il reste quelque chose par
derrière alors qu'est-ce qui
reste la transmutation donc peut
permettre de détruire un certain nombre
d'actinide mineur en particulier
laaméritium qui est le premier qui est
le premier
visé ça détruira probablement pas tous
les actin mur mais si on a déjà détruit
l'améritium on fait un grand pas en
avant parce que l'amritium c'est la
partie la plus thermique des des
déchets et donc en éliminant l'améritium
des du déchet le colier devient moins
thermique et donc on peut concentrer les
les déchets donc qu'on obtient avec ça
c'est un alors on a toujours un stockage
géologique pour tout le reste mais on
peut concentrer les colis c'estàdire que
l'emprise du stockage est bien plus est
bien plus fA ou on peut mettre plus de
choses dans le même stockage on peut le
VO d'une manière ou d'une autre donc je
reviens làdessus sur un stockage c'est
une ressource rare et donc l'optimiser
c'est quelque chose de pertinent et donc
de ce point de vue la transmutation
et la destruction de laamritium
participe à l'optimisation du stockage
il reste une partie d'actinine mineur
qu'on qu'on ne va pas détruire et puis
il reste tous les produits de fission
qui eux aussi ne sont pas détruits donc
à la fin il reste quand même des déchets
à à stocker euh voilà pour ce
commentaire
euh qu'est-ce que oui vous avez parler
des des réacteurs 40 ans euh alors 40
ans par construction ou il y a une
espèce d'ambiguïé là-dessus ça a été
vendu il y a 40 ans en disant vous
inquiétez pas pendant 40 ans tout va
bien ça a été surtout utilisé comme
variable de dimensionnement de la
amortissement donc il s'ag il s'agissait
de dire il marche pendant 40 ans
j'amortis mon investissement si'il va
audelà tant mieux pour moi mais j'ai pas
besoin de faire la démonstration bon et
par ailleurs bon je sors de de mes
attributions Commission nationale
d'évaluation et là je vais marcher sur
les pieds de de la mais la qualification
de du du réacteur de toute façon elle
est le réacteur est requalifié tous les
10 ans par la visite descienale ou
plusment elle est réautorisée tous les
10 ans avec la visite descienale compris
la visite des des 50 ans des 60 ans
éventuellement ou ou ou plus euh ça
dépend d'investissement qui peuvent être
consenti par par l'industriel ça dépend
surtout de l'autorité de Sté qui donne
son autorisation ou pas euh
voilà
euh est-ce que j'ai balayé toutes vos
questions oui c'est le statut de de
l'uranium appauvri je pense que je me
suis exprimé dessus avec l'uranium
appauvri c'est une ressource pour les
RNR et si je veux revenir dessus bon
Astrid on en parle plus c'est du c'est
du passé euh mais il y a de nombreux
projets de de
réacteur porté par le par le par le
privé
euh qui repose sur des réacteurs à
neutron rapide donc euh même en
l'absence d'Astrid he qui était vu comme
le le marchpied pour aller vers vers les
RNR les RNR peuvent revenir euh avec ces
ces projets et peuvent revenir beaucoup
plus vite que que ce qu'on a a pu
imaginer il y a de ou 3 ans après laamon
de
d'astride Monsieur monsieur le Président
à propos de l'uranium appauvri donc vous
avez indiqué que effffectivement c'est
une ressource quasi inépuisable pour une
filièreen mais ceci étant donc d'ors et
déjà un réanrchissement de l'uranium
àauvri apporterait une économie de 7 à 8
ans d'uranium naturel donc en fait la
première étape pourrait consister en cas
de de problème d'approvisionnement sur
les marchés internationaux elle pourrait
consister donc à réenrichir l'uranium
appauvri et donc en fait de suppler les
fournitures d'uranium naturel pendant 7
à 8 années ça c'est la première chose et
par ailleurs concernant le problème de
la sémantique sur prolongement de la
durée de vie EDF appelle donc les
opérations correspondantes le grand
carénage et donc en fait ne ne fait pas
de d'hypothèse sur sur la durée
effectivement d'exploitation des des
centrales ceci étant il y a une quand
même un horizon qui est l'horizon
américain
où
pratiquement on table sur des duré des
durées d'exploitation d'à peu près 80
ans donc il a de la marge cont tenu de
la qualité des des centrales françaises
pour aller plus loin que que ce qui escé
pour le
moment euh oui collègue me signale que
je n'ai pas parlé de
neward bon
je nous n'avons pas évalué le le le
projet neward puisque la partie réacteur
du projet neward c'est c'est à d'autres
personnes de faire ça je vais commenter
la partie
cycle sur la partie C ça nous pose pas
de problème particulier puisque le
combustible est quasiment le même que
celui des des REP habituels de l'pr il
est un peu plus enrichi ça ne change pas
fondamentalement les choses donc il
ressemble beaucoup à celui des pr donc
pour la fabrication et pour l'aval du
cycle ça ne pose pas
d'enjeu ins surmontable
dire en tout cas ce que nous avons
constaté en comparant newward et le
réacteur Rolls-Royce c'est que donc le
projet Rolls-Royce véritablement utilise
des technologies qui sont complètement
éprouvées et s'agissant de newward il y
a tr innovation qui sont peut-être
susceptibles d'apporter de des des gains
de compétitivité mais qui sont également
possiblement facteur de retard par
rapport à à la concurrence étrangère
oui d'autres questions Daniel
salmon merci monsieur le Président c'est
ma première réunion de l'OPEC je sais
pas de combien de temps on dispose mais
tant qu'il faut ok très bien merci non
quelques quelques autres questions je ne
reviendrai pas sur la géopolitique parce
que là on pourrait s'y attarder
longuement et toujours difficile de de
se projeter dans le siècle à venir
lorsque l'on ne sait pas ce qui va se
passer dans les dans les deux ou 3 ans
qui sont devant nous j'iraai sur des
choses beaucoup plus je veux dire terre
à terre ou plutôt dans l'eau puisque je
parle les piscines les piscine de la
Hague sont aujourd'hui saturées on fait
de la place en TASS un peu plus les fut
ce qui n'est pas s'ans poser quelques
questions de de
refroidissement est-ce que vous pouvez
nous donner quelques éléments sur la
construction des nouvelles piscines et
voilà où où est-ce que l'on en est euh
il y a sinon il y a pratiquement un an
jour pour jour nous étions à visiter
CGO le
laboratoire on a vu que notre PPE n'est
toujours pas là mais que il y a eu un
espèce de cavalier qui a fait sauter le
le plafond du nucléaire et que on est
parti sur d'autres perspectives donc ça
veut dire qu'il faut réinterroger
complètement sigo et le nombre de
kilomètres de tunnel voilà quel que vous
avez comme comme information et sur les
les potentialités donc sur 6 Go sinon on
a parlé de l'uranium de
retraitement effectivement ce n'est pas
ce n'est pas une grande partie du
combustible aujourd'hui en France mais
on sait que on l'envoie en Sibérie parce
que c'est une technologie qui est quand
même assez sale et que souvent on
préfère exporter à l'extérieur la saleté
que plutôt que de gérer ça sur les
territoires français mais c'est pour le
nucléaire comme pour autre chose mais
c'est un des éléments sinon si j'ai bien
compris vous occupez quand même de tout
le cycle et donc uranium naturel
également aujourd'hui on importe quand
même plus de 40 % se vient du Kazakhstan
et oubékistan en passant par la Russie
donc là aussi quelques quelques
questions de souveraineté même si
j'entends bien qu'on a un gros stock
d'uranium appauvri mais là aussi quel
est le coût lorsque l'on repart du
l'uranium appauvri pour le réenrichir
mais qui va être beaucoup plus loin
réenrichir puisqu'on l'a déjà appauvri
et quelle est aussi un jour faut se
poser les question de de bilan de bilan
énergétique de tout ça voilà je je
m'arrêterai là sur ce petit flux de
questions
merci je rejoins évidemment les
préoccupations Daniel salmon sur
l'urgence de faire aboutir le projet
CGO puisque on sait qu'on on est dans la
phase terminale pour faire aboutir le le
le projet donc il est il serait
inconcevable de de de ralentir ce ce
projet-l moiuss si je comprends bien et
même d'envisager un autre un autre
projet si les les besoins s'en faisaient
sentir j'avais une question que je vous
avveais pas posé sur le cycle euh vous
disiez tout à l'heure sur les
renouvellements des installations de
retraitement le c'est 2025 la date
butoire pour pouvoir être opérationnel
en 2040 ça veut dire que c'est ce
temps-là que vous estimez 15 ans euh
nécessaire en France pour faire aboutir
un un un projet ça veut dire pour purger
toutes les
tous les recours éventuels sur sur ce
type de de
sujet bien je vais passer la parole à
Christophe pour la partie piscine et
puis je reviendrai sur le sur
co bien bon en ce qui concerne les
piscines il y a effectivement un
engorgement progressif des des piscines
y compris la avec un certain nombre de
mesures que vous avez que vous avez cité
bon qui son évidemment étudier avec tous
les aspects sûreté afférant mais qui ne
ne ne permettent de traiter la question
que pour quelques années
EDF a présenté un projet de de piscine
centralisée de plus grande
capacité
qui qui suit son cours et et qui
pourrait être mise en service quelque
part vers le début des années 2030 ou le
milieu des années 2030 ce qui est
suffisant pour éviter l'engorgement des
piscines encore faut-il effectivement
que ce projet puisse être mis en œuvre à
la Hague complètement
euh ce projet est tout à fait majeur vu
de la Commission en particulier euh
parce que nous estimons que le
l'entreposage sous eau des combustibles
usés est tout à fait préférable à
l'entreposage à sec
entreposage à sec qui est euh euh étudié
par ailleurs comme mesure transitoire
qui est parfois pronné parce que
largement utilisé à l'étranger et
là-dessus la situation est claire
l'entreposage à sec en sûreté est tout à
fait possible et démontré à l'étranger
ce qui n'est pas démontré à ce jour
c'est la capacité d'ouvrir ensuite la
boîte pour récupérer le combustible et
le mettre dans un dans un cycle
industriel de
traitement on n'est pas certain que le
combustible sera manipulable à tel
ancienne qu'X États-Unis les les
Américains envisagent carrément de
prendre le conteneur d'entreposage et de
le stocker tel quel comme ça on nouvrira
jamais la boîte c'est la raison pour
laquelle en particulier pour les MX qui
sont plus chauds la la CNE estime que il
y a besoin d'études
complémentair sur le la l'évolution du
combustible et la capacité qu'on aurait
à le manipuler avant d'envisager d'
stocker des combustible usé qu'on
pourrait éventuellement ne plus savoir
retraiter faute de les manipuler donc ça
c'est c'est c'est c'est un aspect qui
est très lié qui est très lié aux
piscines et qui de notre point de vue
soulligne l'importance et l'urgence du
dossier de
piscine qui pose un problème de de de
mise en place d'acceptation locale et
cetera qui
techniquement n'est pas un dossier
difficile voà
je répondre à votre question sur CGO ou
peut-être ne pas y
répondre alors pour CGO landendra a
déposé sa demande d'autorisation de
création et sa demande d'autorisation de
création repose sur un inventaire de
référence qui est bien calibré et d'un
point de vue industriel savoir enfin
démontrer sur quelque chose qui est figé
ça me paraît juste indispensable donc
d'un point de vue séparation des
variables landra a travaillé sur un
inventaire va faire sa démonstration
cette cette démonstration est à l'étude
par laasn et de manière complémentaire
par par la CNE et on arrivera peut-être
à euh un cigo sur cet inventaire donc là
où je dis séparer les variables c'est
que euh je évidemment il va y avoir de
alors évidemment à l'étude aujourd'hui
de nouveaux de nouveaux réacteurs y
compris de nouveaux types de réacteur
d'ailleurs euh et où vont aller ces ces
déchets alors
je pour moi ce qui est important c'est
que une fois que on a réussi à faire un
CGO ben on a démontré qu'on savait
traiter ces qu'on qu'on savait traiter
ces ces déchets de manière correcte les
futurs déchets euh bah il peut être
traité soit par la capacité d'évolution
de de CGO à condition
que il y a une étude complémentaire
d'adaptabilité qui a une validation par
l'ASN que oui ou non on peut accepter
des des coliss
supplémentaires ça c'est une première
partie de de la réponse la deuxième
partie de la réponse c'est à partir du
moment où je sais construire CG B j'ai
démontré que je savais traiter des des
déchets mais il me paraît important
aujourd'hui de de ne
pas complexifier l'analyse du dossier de
d'autorisation de création en bougeant
les
curseurs pendant le pendant
l'instruction voilà donc j'ai
probablement pas répondu complètement à
votre réponse mais je pense que c'est
important d'avoir ce ce type de de de
référence qui soit qui soit
stable Tex disent très très clairement
que le centre de stockage de de CGO est
conçu pour accueillir les déchets de
l'inventaire de
référence ceci étant il est si Goo doit
être également conçu conçu pour
éventuellement accueillir des substances
qui figurent à l'inventaire de réserve
mais ceci étant donc c'est au niveau de
la conception mais le stockage il est
encore une
fois conçu pour l'inventaire de
référence c'est clairement indiqué dans
les textes et donc je je reprends ce
qu'a dit Vincent c'est tout à fait clair
que il n'y a pas de de de de à moins de
changer les textes il n'y a pas de de
risque que que cet inventaire de réserve
soit considérablement différent de ce
qui est à l'heure actuelle de pardon
l'intentaire de référence soit
considérablement différent de ce qui est
à l'heure actuelle
statué voilà et puis je vais prendre
aussi la question sur le l'uranium
naturel
alors le marché de
alors il se trouve que je m'intéresse à
à ces questions de d'uranium naturel de
part mes mes fonctions en dehors de de
la Commission et il y a une dizaine
d'années je pouvais dire à mes élèves
l'uranium c'est très pratique en le le
pétrole ça ça génère des des problèmes
géopolitique et si vous prenez la carte
des producteurs de pétrole grosso modo
vous avez la carte des crises euh
politique
et voire militaire dans le monde ce qui
n'est pas le cas de l'uranium parce que
l'uranium est plus plus dispersé et dans
des pays réputé stable alors je révise
un petit peu
mon ce type de discours aujourd'hui y
compris devant mes mes élèves
euh bon avec un certain nombre de pays
qui sont plus ou moins stables avec un
certain nombre de pays qui sont dans des
sphères d'influence qui peuvent qui
peuvent bouger d'où les les questions de
de souveraineté qui qui qui surgissent
et et qu'on a abondamment commenté
pendant toute cette toute cette matinée
donc je dis pas qu'il y a un problème
aujourd'hui je dis que c'est
probablement pertinent
de de regarder ces questions de de
manière global et de se mettre en en
position de ne pas dépendre de d'un
certain nombre de de
pays la la question se se complique par
ailleurs avec une consommation de
d'uranium qui doit augmenté très
significativement dans les quelques
dizaines d'années qui viennent enfin je
sans aller à l'échéance du siècle sur
sur les 20 ans qui
viennent regarder la la la les les
projets qui sont en cours en Chine et et
en Russie et on a une consommation de
d'uranium qui doit augmenter de d'un B
30 % dans les dans dans les 10 dans les
10 20 prochaines années euh je reviens
sur le coût du réanchissement alors tout
à l'heure on a dit l'uranium appauvri
c'est une matière au sens où ça peut
être utilisé pour les pour les RNR c'est
également une matière au sens où on peut
la réenrichir et de ce point de vue-là
alors on peut le voir de deux manières
euh certaines sociétés utilisent déjà le
le réenrichissement de l'uranium
appauvri en fonction des conditions du
marché donc en fonction du prix du
réenrichissement il est déjà rentable
aujourd'hui de faire du réenrichissement
de l'uranium euh
appauvri Orano ne fait pas ça Orano
préfère stocker son son uranium appauvri
mais donc il est clair que le coût de
réenrichissement n'est pas
dramatiquement élevé il est quasiment au
prix du marché et àpr dire parfois il
est
même économiquement rentable côté bilan
énergétique c'est pareil le le contenu
énergétique de l'uranium est tellement
gigantesque que quoi qu'on fasse par
derrière le rendement énergétique est
toujours très très très efficace donc la
question n'est pas n'est pas ici la
question est sur l'approvisionnement en
uranium naturel et puis plus que la
disponibilité de l'uranium peut-être la
recomposition de des
flux du marché à l'échelle mondiale sous
différentes pressions sous la pression
de modification significative de la
consommation par certains pays ou des
recompositions qui qui dépendent plus de
considération
géopolitique euh voilà je pense que ça
répond à cette question et puis oui le
donc une précision sur le renouvellement
des des installations 25 2040 euh alors
15 ans c'est pas le temps pour purger
euh tous les recours euh 15 ans c'est le
temps de d'instruction des des dossiers
par les opérateurs pour prendre leur
leur décisions d'investissement et puis
ça compte aussi ces 15 ans la
construction par derrière de manière à
disposer effectivement des installations
en 2040 alors 2025- 2040 c'est pas des
dates qui sont figées cela dit 2040
c'est une date à laquelle il faut euh
faire des choses sur les sur les usines
du cycle alors si c'est 2043 c'est pas
dramatique en tout cas ça attendra pas
2050 donc 2025 ça nous paraît une date
raisonnable pour prendre la décision
sinon on risque de se retrouver comme
les Anglais avec l'absence de décision
qui ben finalement
impose impose sa
marche
Bolot merci monsieur le Président je
voudrais rebondir sur les réponses que
vous avez donné aux collègues sur le
dimensionnement de CGO et l'inventaire
de référence puisque ce sujet de la
capacité d'accueil de de nouveaux
déchets essentiels au regard du du
nouvel horison nucléaire qui a été
dessiné et je voulais savoir si les les
déchets nucléaires issus du dsmr ils
étaient sensiblement différents en terme
de volume de quantité de compacité à
ceux issu des des pr est-ce qu'il y a un
rapport euh entre les les déchets
nucléaires pr SMR est-ce que ce rapport
est équivalent à sui de la puissance
entre les deux
installations alle-y monsieur le
Président
euh bien alors sur les SMR euh donc pour
pour nard pas de grosse
différence newward et pr c'est on va
dire ça ça ne change pas le les les
fondamentaux pour les autres à voir
alors euh il y a déjà une une étude qui
a été menée alors par le l'Académie des
sciences euh des des États-Unis sur le
sur les déchets générés par les les smmr
par rapport à à d'autres
euh l'étude n'est pas complètement
conclusive
euh au sens où elle dit
que la quantité de déchets est un peu
plus grande ou un peu plus petite voire
beaucoup plus grande ou beaucoup plus
petite voilà je résume de manière un peu
crue
euh en pratique il faut regarder point
par point par point et regarder les
technologies
spécifique concernant les Amr la
typologie des déchets sera totalement
différente vous comprenez que si on a
alors j'ai parlé tout à l'heure d'un
réacteur brûleur d'actinide qui repose
sur un réacteur à celle fondu ça n'a
strictement rien à voir avec un
combustible euh classique MOX ou même
euh
uox
euh et c'est en ça que dans ma dans ma
partie de de présentation je trouve que
les s'intéresser dès maintenant à la
fois à la partie combustible et à la
partie avale est indispensable et pour
moi c'est un enfin pour la commission
c'est un point faible des des projets
nous demandons spécifiquement alors je
tous les projets que nous avons
rencontrés nous avons posé cette
question spécifique avec des réponses
qui sont plus ou moins satisfaisantes
mais en tout cas c'est c'est un point
sur lequel on insiste il faut absolument
euh challenger tous ces tous tous ces
projets pour qu'il s'approprie alors en
interne ou avec d'autres d'autres
acteurs la question de de la gestion des
des
déchets bien est-ce que la réponse un
petit peu plus un petit peu moins
beaucoup plus beaucoup moins convient
monsieur bolo s'il n'y a pas d'autres
questions mes chers collègues je vous
propose de d'abord de remercier vraiment
monsieur le Président et et les membres
du CNE pour la présentation et le
travail en amont on parle beaucoup
d'amont et d'aval mais euh là on est sur
la branche aval mais on sait que ça
c'est beaucoup de beaucoup de travail
pour nous présenter ces travaux de
manière d'abord très pédagogique parce
qu'on sait que c'est on va très
rapidement dans le dans le trait
technique euh un petit peu voir beaucoup
et et et vraiment je vous remercie de la
présentation et des des mots employés
pour que ça reste accessible pour les
les béociens que nous nous sommes par
rapport à votre expertise donc merci
beaucoup au rendez-vous l'année
prochaine et mes chers collègues je vous
donne quant à nous rendez-vous le le 9
novembre et contrairement à ce que j'ai
pu dire tout à l'heure ou mardi ça
pourra se faire à l'Assemblée nationale
puisque nessayons de d'alterner dans la
mesure du possible et de la
disponibilité des salles de l'assemblée
et donc le 9 novembre ça pourra se tenir
avec présentation de rapport et de notes
de Christine hargi notamment merci et
bonne bonne fin de journée à
vous y